The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT Open OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
So today, we're
moving along chronologically.
And today, we're going to look
at two films from the 1920s.
And both of these
films were extremely
influential on later
documentary filmmakers, which
is why we want to look at them.
But they have extremely
different sensibilities
and extremely different styles.
And they also have
extremely different visions
of what they want to do
with this new emerging
camera film technology.
And they also are in
dialogue with science
in different kinds of ways.
And we talked some about
science films before,
and that's something
that we're going
to draw out in both of these--
thinking about in relation
to both of these filmmakers.
So as I mentioned in
the last class, the way
that we do these Wednesday
night classes is,
generally, I introduce
the films that we're
going to be talking about, then
we watch part of the films,
and then we have group
discussion about it afterwards.
Because we don't
have enough time,
unfortunately, we can't
watch the documentaries
in their entirety, but we do
have copies of most things
over in the DV lab office.
And for a lot of the films,
we have three copies of each.
So if you want to borrow
DVDs and watch the rest of it
at some point if
you have a chance,
you can also get them out.
Take them out with
Dave in addition
to getting camera
equipment from him.
OK, so the first film
we're going to look at
is a film called
Nanook of the North.
I don't know how many
have ever heard of Nanook.
It's quite a famous
documentary film.
And as you know
from the reading,
it was made by Robert Flaherty.
It came out in 1922.
And this film was made about
Inuit peoples who are often
referred to historically
by Europeans and Americans
as Eskimo, people who group
that lived historically
as well as in the contemporary
northern Canada and the Arctic.
And the film ostensibly tracks
the life of an Eskimo family
and their struggles to survive
in the harsh Arctic wilderness.
And in thinking about the
relationship between science
and documentary in
this class, there's
a couple of reasons
why Nanook of the North
is important to think about.
First of all, because it's
often credited as being
the first documentary film.
And as we talked about in
the last class, the term
documentary itself wasn't
really coined until the 1930s.
So you didn't really, at this
point, it was still too early,
you didn't really
have a distinct genre
of documentary film.
But for documentary
film theorists,
when they go back and look at
the history of various kinds
of films, they often
position Nanook
of the North as being the first
documentary film historically.
And it's also been influential
among anthropologists
in the social sciences
because many people saw it
as a precursor to
ethnographic film.
And if you're not sure about
anthropology or ethnographic
film, we're going to be talking
about that a couple of classes
later down the line.
So there'll be more discussion
about that coming up.
So I mentioned in
the last class how,
from the very beginning,
from the time that you
had the Lumiere
brothers inventing
their camera in the 1890s,
the early history of the film
were very international
in origin.
So we talked about
how the Lumieres,
they immediately
had their operators
going out at different parts of
the world, taking these films,
showing them to audiences.
So from the very,
very beginning,
it was a very international--
it had very international scope.
And I also mentioned
in the last class
that you have to keep
in mind this was also
the colonial period.
So this was really the height
of European colonialism.
1/3 of the landmass of the
globe during this period
was controlled by the
British in some form,
either through direct colonies
or indirect protectorates.
Some people argue that 1/4
of the world's population
were under some form
of British dominion.
So between the various
major European powers--
and the US also had its
hands in some of this,
but it was very much a
colonial international terrain.
And so you have to think about
the dissemination of cameras
and early films in
that kind of context
as they moved internationally.
And you also have to think
in the context of the US
and Canada, you
also had internally
colonized people
like Native Americans
or the Inuit in Arctic Canada.
And I don't know how
many of you have talked
about this in basic
history classes elsewhere,
but in the 19th
and 20th centuries
you might know that
ideas of social evolution
were very common.
Any sense of what those ideas
of social evolution were about?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah, I
mean, some people refer to it
as social Darwinism.
I mean, that was a later strand.
It also had earlier
historical origins.
But, basically the idea
in much of 19th century
European and American
thought that you
could rank societies
hierarchically,
that societies were ranked.
There were some
societies that were
seen as being more primitive
and more traditional.
And they were seen
as being ranked.
And the groups that were
seen as being the most
civilized, or modern,
or progressive
were European countries.
And Americans thought, of
course, Americans were.
But it was very much this
idea that somehow societies
could be ranked in a certain
kind of way and the idea
that societies would
evolve or transform
from being more primitive
or traditional to being
more modern.
So these kinds of
stereotypes and ideas
were very pervasive
during this period.
And many of these
stereotypes then
about non-western societies
were extremely negative.
And partly, that came out
of the colonial context.
It was part of
the understandings
of this hierarchical
relationships between people
in different parts of the world.
But in addition to the
overtly negative stereotypes
of non-western people, you
also had a certain kind
of romantic Rousseauian ideas
of the noble primitive savage
that certain
primitive peoples were
seen as kind of
a romantic light,
as being closer to nature,
as being potentially more
authentic.
So there was this kind of
countercurrent in European
and American thought where at
least some people would argue,
well, modern society
is corrupting
and these non-western
more, quote-unquote,
"primitive peoples" are
somehow more authentic,
they haven't been corrupted
by modern contemporary life.
And so many people have talked
about Nanook of the North
as being a film that came
out of this romantic,
this romantic
primitive tradition.
It was a wildly popular film.
And we talked in the last class
about how the early science
films were also part of
popular entertainment.
They were shown in movie
theaters with Vaudeville shows.
So entertainment was very much a
part of the early film terrain.
And Nanook as entertainment
was wildly successful.
There were press kits.
And I actually--
I can't remember
whether I had this online, but
for those of you interested,
I'll pass this around.
This is some of the
early press kits
that when Nanook was
being shown in theaters,
they had all these ideas for
shopkeepers about what you
should do to publicize it,
and all these ideas about how
you should build
igloos in your lobby,
and put around fake snow.
And so anyway, the press
the press kit from the 1920s
is quite interesting
about ideas about how
Nanook should be publicized.
So Nanook, it turned in
kind of a pop culture craze.
All these commercial tie ins,
Eskimo pies became a big item
in pop culture.
So one of the questions
to think about then was,
why was this kind of Romantic
Primitivism so popular
at the time?
And Anna Grimshaw
is one author who's
argued that in
order to understand
the popularity of
films like Nanook
and these kinds
of ideas, you have
to think about the US and Europe
in the context of the aftermath
of World War I.
And what she argued was
that the First World
War was so deeply traumatic
for so many people
that it caused them to
question the 19th century
strong faith in ideas of
science and technology
as always leading to
greater rationality.
And for a lot of people,
those kinds of ideas
that society was just evolving
in this kind of upward way,
and everything was
becoming more progressive,
and that science and
technology were going
to bring only wonderful things.
The first World War was
a very strong challenge
for a lot of people.
And she argues that there
were a couple of responses
to this, that surrealism, if you
think about other kinds of art
movements like
surrealism and Dadaism
were one kind of response,
because the surrealist ideas
of breaking down rationality
and focusing on dream states,
for example, that was
one kind of response
to that kind of disillusionment.
And she argues that
another response was
a certain kind of romantic
primitivism, this idea, then,
that, well, these supposedly
primitive peoples were leading
more simple authentic
lives and that they
didn't have to worry about
the horrors of modern warfare
or the alienation
of modern life.
So there was this fascination
at that particular historical
moment with these
kinds of groups.
So in addition to
focusing on what
were thought of at the time
as being primitive peoples,
there were also the
romantic tradition
has historically focused
very strongly on nature.
And there was often
expressed a kind
of longing for an untamed
nature and wild spaces,
which was associated with the
fact that many of those spaces
were being transformed because
of colonialism or because
of economic expansion.
So there was often a kind of
nostalgia for certain kinds
of landscapes.
So Nanook was a film that
brought both of those trends
together, an interest
in a certain kind
of romantic primitivism
that was also
tied to certain
kinds of nostalgia
for certain kinds of
natural landscapes.
And you've read a
bit in the readings
about Flaherty's
background, the filmmaker.
You know that he was the
son of a mining engineer,
he grew up in northern Michigan.
He was very kind of outdoorsy
type ever since he was a kid.
And he started out in
the north because he was
searching for mining deposits.
And then, he increasingly
began working on film projects
with the Inuit.
You might have read
about how he had
an early version of the film
that ended up being set on fire
and destroyed.
And he ended up going back
and reworking it completely.
But anyway, we can talk
more about Flaherty
after you've seen
a bit of the film.
So just a couple
of things I want
you to be thinking
about as we watch
a bit of Nanook of the North.
The question of, why was it
so appealing to so many people
at the time?
Why is this considered to be
a classic, a classic film?
And it still is often on the
list of top films ever made,
you'll find Nanook.
The second question
to think about
is, how is it constructed as
a film, as a documentary film?
How is it put together,
how is it made?
And the third
question is, what are
the kinds of representations
at work in the film about Inuit
as a group?
So just a few things to be
thinking about as we watch it.
We're going to watch about
20 minutes to half an hour
of the film.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
OK.
Reactions?
Thoughts?
What do you all think?
AUDIENCE: For something made
in the early 1990s, it wasn't--
it was pretty good.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it is.
It kind of holds up, doesn't it?
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
So what did you like about it?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
I guess it just had that
old movie feel to it.
It reminded me of the
last STS class I was in,
we watched a few clips from
Charlie Chaplin's Modern Times.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Yeah, that's great.
AUDIENCE: And it
just reminded me
of, like, that
similar type of movie.
Just has a feel good type.
I don't know how to
express it personally.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Other thoughts?
Comments?
AUDIENCE: It's cool,
because it's stuff
like I've never seen, like,
as far as, like, the igloo.
I mean, even though
nowadays you could probably
go out there a lot easier.
But yeah, like they don't
show that type of stuff
because it's more,
like, not following
one person in modern films
about visiting places.
So yeah.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah,
and, I mean, we're
going to be talking
particularly when
we look at Vertov's
film, which is
a film very much about modern
technology at the time.
So again, thinking
about Flaherty
as somebody who's partly
reacting against that.
And so here is like
a real appreciation
with that igloo building.
It's like, ah, look at
here's a technology that
wouldn't be considered modern
by contemporary Southerners
as Inuit people would
refer to people down here.
But isn't this
fascinating watching
the way that they
put it together
and the amount of ingenuity
that goes into doing it?
So it's about technology
in an interesting way,
but different than some
of the focus on technology
that we'll see in some
of the other films.
Jessica, you had your hand up?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah,
I was going to say
what I found interesting,
or at least what
got me really interested in
the film was that it's, like,
a totally different way of
life, different from the viewers
in that day when it was
published or shown and now.
I think that was what
really fascinated me.
And it was just interesting
how I think how they
interacted with the filmer.
Like, sometimes they look at
the camera and sometimes they--
I don't know.
Sometimes it seemed scripted.
Like, the fishing part
where he's, like, there's
all these different angles.
And I was like, what, like,
how is he there, like,
all the time?
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Yeah, so that's
an important point that
we should go back to
is how the piece
was put together.
Maybe we could talk
about the film more
generally and then go
back to those questions
about how it was put together.
Oh, and I should just say the
parts that you didn't see,
for any of you who get a
chance to watch the rest of it,
there's a number of really
interesting hunting scenes.
So there's more
with them fishing
and then there's also
a very famous scene
with a seal trying to
hook a seal through an ice
hole, a very famous
walrus hunting scene.
So a lot of it's hunting.
And then, there's also
a big storm comes up
and they have to get to safety.
And so basically it's
about day-to-day survival.
So that's the pieces
that you didn't see.
But then, what you started
out by saying, the fascination
with this way of life,
I mean, one thing
to keep in mind
at the time period
and it's still true
still true today,
that one of the
things that people
were interested in with
the very early films
was using it as a way
to explore or gain
some knowledge, however
superficial or deep, of people
in other places.
So you can think of it
during a time period
when contemporary tourism in
with the ease which we do it
was obviously not an
option for many people.
So a fascination
with film is a way
to get some sense
of what life was
like in different places being
a primary interest for people
in early cinema.
Other-- Matt, I think
you had your hand up.
AUDIENCE: I found
it interesting,
obviously in modern day
you had a narrator going on
while they're doing
the action, but you
had to preface it as much as you
could but as short as he could.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: What?
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: He had the
preface every scene as much
as you could, but in
short of the sentences
as he could since you can't
just fill screen with two
paragraphs worth of writing.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Right.
So because it's a silent film
and there's no narration,
there's no dialogue.
So to try to explain
things for audiences
who wouldn't be familiar, these
really brief intro titles.
Yeah.
And quite evocative
for a popular audience,
many of the titles in
terms of picking interest.
AUDIENCE: I think
definitely what
you were saying about how
different these people look
or have been
represented, I think
there is really this
interplay of similarities
and differences.
What's most striking about
the film, like, he has--
Flaherty has made
all the efforts
to show them as very different,
for the environment they live
is nothing, the audience have
seen or can even imagine,
they're completely unfamiliar
with the gramophone
or at least they're
represented to be so.
There is, like, absolutely no--
and yet at the
same time, they're
very similar to kind of a
European nuclear family.
The wife is beautifully
cleaning the window,
and the kids are
given their medicine,
and they play while
the father works.
So there is also something
kind of reassuring.
Like, these people
are so different
and yet they are
they're like us.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
So let's so let's
talk about this.
So one of the questions I
asked you to think about
is representations of the
Inuit in this film and also
the question about
why it would have
been appealing at the time.
And so what you're saying
goes a bit to both of those.
But can we draw
that out a bit more?
So what was the
image of the Inuit
that Flaherty was trying to
construct through this film?
Go.
AUDIENCE: I think that,
I mean, a big part of it
was, like, the music.
But like, it made the
Inuit lifestyle seem very,
they said, like, they were
happy go lucky, even though
like their lifestyle is--
like, building an igloo is
not, like, fun for any means,
I'm sure.
So, like, they are portrayed
as, like, it almost
seems kind of like storybook
with, like, the prefaces,
and then it's, like, the
parents are building the igloo
and then the kids are playing.
Like, everything seems,
like, easy and fun.
But I guess the
dangers that they
face in a day-to-day
lifestyle, like the starvation,
isn't really brought
across in the film.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
If we had seen the
hunting scenes,
you would have got
a bit more of that
because the walrus
scene is shown to be
a very dangerous enterprise.
But anyway, but your
larger point being,
again, these
questions they have,
how are they being represented?
Any thought building on
these questions, comments?
AUDIENCE: I mean the
childlike, everything
is kind of cute, ingenious,
children, even the starting
scene when all of them
supposedly come out
of the tiny boat
and they're kind
of smiling in this clumsy
way, and there is, like,
no self-reflection, there
is no quotes from them,
I'm sure they
participate in the film,
but they're not presented as
being engaged in the film.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
So there's definitely
a sense of humor
in a lot of the film, which
we can think of that as part
of the reason why it was
appealing at the time,
because there's parts are
quite funny in addition
to the insanely cute
parts with the kids.
There's actually some
incredibly cute stuff
that you didn't see
of some of the kids.
They make these
little snow animals
and then they have
these little toy bow
and arrows that they're
shooting them with.
It's just, like,
the cutest thing.
Everybody goes, like, aw
when I show it in my classes.
So there's the use
of humor, there's
cute images of kids as a way
to create a sense of appeal
as part of it.
But again, these larger
questions that you're raising,
I mean-- and Sean mentioned this
also with this the description
of them as
happy-go-lucky Eskimos--
what's potentially being
left out of the picture?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I mean, actually, my
impression was of the opposite
that, I don't know, I
think it's very subjective.
But I thought, building
up on your idea
that social evolution
in the hierarchy,
I think it was more
trying to show how we
think of the primitive people.
I think we have
this miserable life.
They have to starve, they don't
have modern modern technology,
so they have to put up
with really awful stuff.
But then, we see that
they're happy children.
They still live even though
they have to go hunting.
But they still,
they're are people.
They have a happy life and they
enjoy their life just as much
as we do with all the war,
and modernity, and technology
that they have.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Serena,
do you have a [INAUDIBLE]??
AUDIENCE: Yeah, no, I think also
it shows how hard working they
really are, because all
this stuff they're doing,
it's something that we
wouldn't know how to do.
Like, if we went out there,
we couldn't do it ourselves.
And so even though
it's different
and, like, it might not
be as complex as something
that we think now is
modern technology,
it's like, they're working
really hard, which is kind of--
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
So I mean, what a lot
of you are building on,
I mean, there's kind of two
contradictory things going on
here.
I mean, in line with the kind
of romantic primitivist ideas
at the time, there is a
certain portrayal of Inuit
where you don't see much--
you don't see their
interaction with Europeans.
I mean, you did see in the part
that you saw the interaction
with the trader.
But that's the only
bit in the whole film
that actually shows
interactions with the Europeans.
And there's a very long
history in this region of--
whether Russians, or
Canadians, or whoever coming up
and having very problematic
power relationships with Inuit
people up in that region,
and you don't really
get that other than the
short scene with the trader
and where it's all
presented as funny and cute.
So you don't have a sense
of the historical context
in which people are living.
For those of you--
and I know you
have done different sets of
reading, because most of you
just did the required reading.
And Catarina did the
recommended reading
where she has a little
bit of extra added info.
But there are certain
kinds of the things
that got left out of the film.
And we'll see this a little
bit when we see another clip.
But the fact that
people use rifles
at this point, the rifles,
Flaherty deliberately
had people not appear
with rifles in the film.
He had them dress
in a way that people
might have historically,
although in some cases,
like, supposedly the
polar-skinned pants people
in this area didn't wear.
But he had them dress that way.
So one of the ways that it
gets talked about by Flaherty
was that he argues
at some point--
what's the quote?
I have it written down here.
"That in order to capture
the essence of something,
that one often has
to distort a thing
to catch its true spirit."
And what he did
a lot in the film
was shape what he was
filming in a way that
accorded with ideas of how he
thought Inuit people had been
in the past.
This kind of mythic
portrayal of them,
what he assumed they would
have been like in a pure,
quote, unquote, "past" before
contact with Europeans.
And so he has this
kind of-- some people
refer to as a
salvage ethnography
kind of perspective where
it's kind of interest
in these people, but also
interest in what they
would have been like
prior to European contact.
And so there's a lot of
taking certain things out
of the picture that
didn't fit with that.
The problematic
power relationships
in which people were, the
economic relationships that
were there, you don't
really see that.
You don't see people
reflecting on their situation,
although with subtitles,
granted, it would be--
I mean, without subtitles that
would be more difficult to do.
But you don't necessarily
get a sense of people
as being complicated,
people who are
having their whole range of
thoughts in relation to this.
That scene with the gramophone
scene, so one thing--
as Catarina knows from
the reading that she did--
actually, Flaherty worked
very closely with Inuit
people in the
making of the film.
He was very dependent on people.
The people that he was
working with day-to-day
were his Inuit
friends and people
that he was working with
as he made the film.
And-- sorry, I just lost
my train of thought.
So actually, the people that
he was working with actually
had a fair amount--
quite a bit of
technical knowledge
that they gained by
working on this film.
And so some of the
Inuit people that he
worked with, they
took the camera apart,
they put the camera
back together,
they did some of the shooting.
They were very involved
in the filmmaking process
and in the technologies of
filmmaking in a way that's
not acknowledged.
And in that gramophone
scene-- what
is the implication of
that gramophone scene when
Nanook bites the record?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah,
that is this portrayal
that's that appears
to be showing, like,
look how this is so
completely foreign to people,
these kinds of
European technologies.
Isn't it funny and
isn't it bizarre?
And this is so weird, and I
had to even take a bite of it.
But the reality was that
Flaherty was working closely
with the person who gets
called Nanook in the film.
That wasn't his real name.
And Nanook actually-- the
person who plays Nanook--
suggested a lot of the
scenes, was very involved
in thinking up the film,
again, and other people
as well working a lot with
the technology to make it.
But all of that gets
written out of the picture.
You don't see that.
That's outside the frame.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well,
there's a funny moment
in the very first inner title
sequence, the very long one,
where he says, poor
Nanook hung around,
trying to get me to
stay for another year,
talking about all the
great films we could make.
And to me that kind of rings
true because filmmaking
is really fun and this guy is
collaborating with Flaherty.
And he doesn't want it to end.
But the way, of course, it's
presented in the inner titles,
it's this simple,
naive, but noble person
who has this simplistic
idea of what they're doing.
And isn't it charming that he
wants to continue to do it?
But if you think of
him as a collaborator,
it's like, wow, this is great.
Let's keep doing this
because this is so exciting.
And that one little thing,
really, to me, kind of rings
very true.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
So as Inuit partners
being these unacknowledged
collaborators in the film
and, in part, being
unacknowledged because Flaherty
wants to present this is
about a pre-European contact
period where somehow
I'm capturing
the essence of these
primitive people.
And actually, what
people later discovered
that wasn't actually an actual
family, that the women who get
portrayed as the wives of Nanook
were actually the common law
wives of Flaherty himself.
It was not an uncommon thing
during the colonial period
for European white
men in the colonies
to have relationships
with women in the places
they were working.
He fathered children
in the north
that were not acknowledged
by his American wife.
So he had these very
complicated relationship
to the Inuit people
that he was working
with it that is completely
left out of the film.
So on the one hand,
you have all of that.
And on the other hand, one of
the issues that Catarina also
raised is the kind
of reassuring sense
that all these people appear
to be so different in the film,
but they also seem very
familiar in a sense that,
here's this family.
Watch how the family is working.
But something else to keep in
mind, I mean, this is something
that was quite innovative
about what Flaherty was doing
was the fact that he
was taking these images,
but he was focusing on
particular individuals.
And he was focusing on a family.
A lot of photographs you
would find at the time
during the colonial period,
and a lot of films after this
as well would often focus
on non-western peoples
as ethnic types.
So you wouldn't necessarily
see photos, for example,
of individuals.
You might see a photograph
of an African woman that
says Bantu woman with basket
on her head or something
like that.
Much of the visual imagery
was about these racial types
rather than about individuals.
And something that was
distinctive about this film
was the focus on
particular individuals.
So that was both breaking with
much of the contemporary usage
at the time, and
it was also a way
to pull audiences in because
audiences became fascinated
with this family, with
particular individuals,
and they end up following--
it becomes more of a story,
it becomes more of a narrative.
And that also, for
film theorists,
seen as being one of the major
contributions of this film,
that instead of random
images of different places,
the pieces get put
together to create
a story around this family.
And the story being
about the struggle
to survive in this
kind of context.
CHRIS BOEBEL: We
should change tape.
If you change tape.
So we are going to take
just like a 2-minute break
to change tape in the cameras.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So
just to recap a bit.
So for Flaherty, then,
this idea that he
had that many people at the time
had that the Eskimo way of life
was disappearing.
And so it was important to
capture the way that life would
have been before
pre-European contact
before that was completely lost.
So that being part of
the idea of salvage
ethnography at the time,
which even Flaherty was not
an anthropologist,
but that being
part of some of
the larger language
around the stuff that he would
have been participating in.
But let's, before
we go on, let's just
talk a little bit about
how this was shot.
So how was it shot?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Any ideas?
Thoughts?
CHRISTINE WALLEY: About,
how is it put together?
What was the impact of the
way that it was put together?
CHRIS BOEBEL: I mean, one way
to think about it, for those
of you who were here last week,
think about the way the Lumiere
shorts were shot, some of
the other stuff we've seen,
and compare to this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
because otherwise I'm
just going to be [INAUDIBLE].
And then I also heard somehow
that they showed it to Nanook,
or, like, I don't
know if it said it
on the screen [INAUDIBLE].
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
So again, in terms of his
collaborative relationships
with Inuit people that
he was working with,
they would have been
seeing the rushes
as they were created and also
had input into what was shot.
So supposedly Nanook and some
of the other people had ideas.
And as Chris was
mentioned earlier,
that the person who plays
the person of Nanook
was really into the
whole filmmaking process
and supposedly was always
coming up with ideas--
why don't we shoot
this, why don't we
shoot this-- because he was
having fun and enjoying it.
But so Flaherty was also
getting feedback from people
as he was shooting it.
And some people have argued that
even the aesthetic sensibility
of the film, in the clips we saw
you didn't see so much of it.
But some of them are
just these gorgeous pans
across the landscape that
just have the snow and ice,
and then you might see a
few dogs in the distance.
And it's very similar to
Inuit painting styles.
And some people have argued
either that Flaherty was deeply
influenced by Inuit
painting styles,
or it might have been also
some of his Inuit collaborators
themselves using the camera
and shooting it according
to their own aesthetics.
So again, this kind
of Inuit influence
on what Flaherty was doing,
that's not really more formally
acknowledged.
But other thoughts on
how it was put together?
[? Anita? ?]
AUDIENCE: It was
interesting because I
think it's very similar to the
kind of movies we watch today.
And there's not an
establishing shot,
like going with close ups.
And it's very interesting
how it exactly
follows that, or I
guess that's what primarily
invented the kind of idea
of using different shots
to tell the story instead
of like personalize the story
and show these characters
as an individual.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah, one
thing that is interesting
is that in the 20 years
between Cheese Mites
and some of the
other shorts that we
saw last week and this--
or slightly more than 20 years--
film grammar has been
really established.
DW Griffith has been pioneering
that with fiction films,
narrative films, which
again, have a lot of overlap
with "documentary,"
quote, unquote,
which isn't even really
a term that people
are using at this point.
But yeah, close ups,
establishing shots,
pans, all of those are really
new and kind of exciting things
that by this point, people are
used to watching in theaters.
But they're not that old.
And it completely
changes the way
the camera and then the audience
"receives the information,"
quote, unquote, and the
way that the stories are
edited, created, manipulated.
And I'm not using that
term in a pejorative way,
although obviously there's
a lot of manipulation here.
And it gives you just
all of this latitude.
I mean, think about how the
characters are introduced,
Nanook and his family.
Title, name, close up.
And the close up just
extends for a long time.
And that's basically
telling you,
pay attention to these people.
Pay attention to
these human beings.
And you're just asked
to, right at eye level--
camera's right at eye
level-- look at their faces
for a very long time or a
comparatively long time.
And that is something that
just completely locates you
in what the film is
going to be about,
who it's going to be about
in a very powerful way, which
of course, to us, is
kind of second nature
because we read
films all the time.
But it's a big deal.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Also,
just some of these terms,
in case some of you aren't
aware, establishing shots.
Do you know what that is?
A wide shot of whatever
the place is, so
that when a viewer sees it they
know, ah, this is the place.
So for example, if
you're going to do
an establishing shot of MIT,
you might stand on Mass Ave.
and do the big dome.
Sort of like, ah, what you're
going to see next is at MIT.
So here, establishing
shots helps
the viewer locate where
the action is going to be.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Or in the Eskimo
or the igloo building scene,
a wide shot that shows
the people working,
and the kids over
here, and where
the igloo is taking shape.
So you're kind of
located in space.
And then you might go into
close ups of the knives,
and the people working,
and the kids playing.
The scene gets fragmented
after the establishing shot.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And also,
reaction shots, which Flaherty
didn't have the earlier version
of the film that burned,
but he has in this version.
So again, coming out
of the film grammar
that's emerging out of fiction
film, so reaction shots
then being where you see action
happening with one person
and then another person
reacting to that.
And in order to do
that with the camera,
you really have to
have two cameras going.
Or you have to reshoot
something and reenact something
with a different camera angle
if you only have one camera.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So I mean,
imagine in this class
if we had one camera
and not three,
and we ask you all to
stay after and reproduce
all your comments.
That would be one
camera shooting
as if we had multiple cameras.
And that's essentially
what Flaherty was doing.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: And
there's a very nice quote
in Barnouw, one of the
readings for today,
that talks about this issue.
"Flaherty had
apparently mastered,
unlike previous
documentarists,"--
excuse me-- "the
grammar of film as it
had evolved in the film
and the fiction film.
This evolution had not
merely changed techniques,
it had transformed the
sensibilities of audiences.
The ability to
witness an episode
for many angles and distances
seen in quick succession,
a totally surrealistic privilege
unmatched in human experience."
I mean, again, if you
just had a camera, that's
not the way the camera would
actually be seeing or recording
things.
"Had become so
much a part of film
viewing that it
was unconsciously
accepted as natural."
So much of the shooting style
that we just take for granted,
this is showing us what's
really going on the place,
is an artificial construction.
But we don't necessarily
recognize it as such
because we're so used
to it being put together
in that kind of way.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And
it relates back
to the whole
question of the frame
that we talked about
in the first class.
And it's going to be just a
huge preoccupation for everyone
as you make your own films.
What do you put in the frame?
And not just in a
particular shot,
but how does what
you put in that frame
relate to what you put in
the frame of the next shot,
and the shot after that?
And how does one
influence the other?
And then, when you're
editing, what order
do you put it all in?
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Mm-hmm.
And one other issue
to think about here
is, how is the editing done?
So the editing here being
described as continuity
editing.
In other words, the editing
is done in such a way
as to give the viewer
the sense of illusion,
a realist sense of illusion
of being in the place
and experiencing things,
which is, as you'll see later
when we see the Vertov film
with man with the movie camera,
completely different from
the kind of editing that
was coming out of
Soviet filmmaking
during this time period.
So a certain kind
of editing meant
to capture that sense
that you're in a place, so
a realistic sensibility.
But it's a realistic
sensibility, but, again,
keep in mind that's not
how the eye or the camera
necessarily actually sees.
That's a construction that
we take as natural rather
than it simply being that.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And we're
so used to watching films
at this point that
we don't even--
I mean, unless we
suddenly become
interested in how films
are constructed, most of us
don't even think about it.
We don't even think about the
multiple shots, and angles,
and how they're
fitting together,
and how our brain and our
experience of watching
other films is assisting us
in making sense of something.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: OK.
So these kinds of
questions about how
the film is put
together, we're going
to be talking about more when we
see Vertov's Man with the Movie
Camera that was made in 1929.
But before we jump to
that, just to follow up
on this question of
representations of Inuit
a little bit, I just want
to show you a short bit
from a film that was
made in the '90s called
Nanook Revisited that was done
by a French filmmaker who went
back into the area where Nanook
was shot and talked to people,
Inuit people who lived in that
area about the making of Nanook
of the North and
their reactions to it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We need a little light on.
Can we get a little light?
We just need to be
able to fast forward.
Oh, never mind.
- Friday, April 18, 1988, we
are now flying towards Inukjuak,
at the north eastern
borders of the Hudson Bay,
hardly ever noted on maps.
Nevertheless, this
small village has
been the seat of a
cinematographic adventure which
will create decisive
change in cinema
after doing so with the life
of the little Eskimo community.
The scene takes place in 1920.
An American of Irish
origins decides
to go and shoot a film on the
life of a small Eskimo group.
Nowadays, we call
it a documentary.
But at the time, it
didn't have a name
and the plan seemed extravagant.
The film is called Nanook.
The filmmaker, Robert Flaherty.
For the historians of cinema,
he is the father of documentary.
Today, we are heading towards
Inukjuak, 68 years after him,
bringing with us
a tape of his film
and 70 pictures found in
the archives of [INAUDIBLE]..
Flaherty enters Inukjuak,
then called Port Harrison,
during summer, 1920.
He will stay there a year.
He writes in his journal.
"On August 15, we drop anchor
at the mouth of the Innuksuak
River.
Less than half a mile
away, we discover
fastened onto the hillside, five
desolated and melancholy huts
which formed the
whole of the station.
The inhabitants of Port
Harrison are the poorest people
I've ever seen.
The day following our
arrival, the mayor
announces on the radio
that we are organizing
a projection of Nanook."
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
This film of Robert Flaherty
was shot towards 1920,
a long time ago.
Today, you're
shooting a film on us,
but Flaherty's was
the very first one.
This great film has been
seen all over the world.
Our friends, filmmakers
come from the other side
of the ocean from a far country.
They're going to watch
with them this film
and pictures of those times.
[END PLAYBACK]
CHRISTINE WALLEY: OK, so
you saw a bit of that.
And again, I'll leave the rest--
I'll leave the VHS tapes in DV
lab in case anybody wants to,
you can make appointments with
Amberly Steward in the anthro
office if you want to
borrow our TV and VCR
and watch it in the small
conference room we have,
in case anybody wants to
see the rest of these films.
But I also just
wanted to show you
a little bit of a
piece called Starting
Fire with Gunpowder that
was made by Inuit media
makers themselves.
I mean one of the things--
I mean, so you have
Nanook Revisited,
which is an interesting
historical perspective
in the '80s.
At that point, as you can
see from the documentary,
media making by
Inuit producers was
becoming a quite interesting
movement in this region,
both in fiction film and in
terms of documentary film.
I don't know-- how many have
heard of the film Antanarjuat--
I'm not sure exactly
how to pronounce it--
The Fast Runner?
I think it was
about five years ago
it won a major award at Cannes.
It was the first
Inuit-written, acted,
produced fiction film
that did quite well.
And we're actually going
to see Zach Kunuk has
another documentary film
that he just recently made
about climate change that
we're going to be watching
a little later in class.
But also in this
region, you have,
through the Canadian
government, you
had Inuit peoples who were
living in this area were
able to obtain funds.
They pressed for funds to
fund some of their own TV film
program.
So there's also
documentary work that's
been made by Inuit
documentary makers
for local TV audiences
in this area.
So I'm just going to let you
see a couple of minutes of that
so you get a sense of what some
of that image making is like.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[NON-ENGLISH CHANTING]
- I think Inuit are not
shy of television or radio.
One of the main reasons
is that they've always
been very communicating
kind of people.
But it has been very
slow because they
would take messages from
one community to another,
from one region to
another only by adopting.
It was only through
word of mouth
that they were able to
pass this message on.
Not having any written
history, this form
of communication,
radio and television,
was as old as it was new, an
oral form of communication.
- [INAUDIBLE] is great.
We are a communicator people.
Our language is
called Inuktitut.
They are far more films
and television shows
made in Inuktitut than there are
books written in our language.
I am Ann Meekitjuk Hanson.
I'm a broadcaster, a
journalist, and a storyteller.
This is a story of
Inuit television.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[INAUDIBLE] White man's TV
arrives suddenly in the Arctic.
It was very seductive
to many of us.
But the exposure to that
much English language
could have wiped out our
culture in a single generation.
We had to find our own
broadcasting voice.
Inuit television started as
a backlash in Northern Quebec
where the introduction
of white man's TV
was met by stiff resistance.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[END PLAYBACK]
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
OK, unfortunately we
don't have time to watch more,
but it's really interesting.
So this soap opera
partly dealing
with issues of substance abuse
in the area among young people,
and it took the part of
things like glue sniffing.
Anyway, so there's probably
educational soap operas,
and there's a really
interesting series
that they did that's
kind of an Inuit
version of Superman for
kids, which is really fun,
[INAUDIBLE].
But anyway, so if anybody wants
to borrow it, I recommend it.
It's a really
interesting documentary
about Inuit media making.
So reactions, thoughts
about all this?
I mean, the kinds of
representations, well,
different questions for
each, but let's maybe
talk about Nanook
Revisited first,
which was the first
one that you saw.
So at least in the bit
that you were able to see,
how was Nanook understood
at that historical point
when they were filming
in the '90s, late '80s?
AUDIENCE: It seemed
like they still
had their relatives, like,
their grandparents might
have been in the film.
And then it's also
interesting to see how,
since it was filmed
in the late '80s,
and this is like,
oh, the modern view
of what it's like now there,
and it's kind of like that.
It was like 20 or 30 years ago.
[INAUDIBLE] Takes you
back in time again.
AUDIENCE: It will be interesting
to see why people were, like,
what was funny about the film.
They were laughing so loud.
Was it because--
I mean, the film
already was representing
things that would have
been funny at the time.
So probably even funnier
for people who remembered
who were children then.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's home
movies in some ways, yeah.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Uh-huh, Ben?
AUDIENCE: I find it interesting.
It's kind of like deja vu,
for lack of better words
and how they all packed the
hall to watch the movie,
that everyone packed to watch
six to eight years before.
Now it's still, in a sense, it
brought the community together.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, so you have kind of
two different things going on.
On the one hand,
as people say, this
is an important
historical record.
Because those kinds of visual
documents from the time period
aren't available otherwise.
And so, as it gets
mentioned in the film,
in some ways the images and the
photographs taken by Flaherty
become this big family album
where people get to, like, ah,
I remember so-and-so,
I remember so-and-so.
And all this
laughing, yeah, it's
hard to know exactly what
the laughing is about.
I mean, is it just the fun of
seeing themselves in people
they know, or is it also because
the construction of the film
is different than the way that
they would have put it together
and so it seems
funny in that way?
I mean, it might
be a bit of both.
CHRIS BOEBEL: People
that they know
dressed in polar bear pants.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Right.
Yes.
Exactly.
Which, again, was done
for Southern audiences.
So it might be some
mix of the two.
So you have-- I just
lost my train of thought.
I had some point
that I was leading to
and I've just forgotten it,
but it'll come back to me.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well, one
quick point I would make
is it's also interesting to,
then, start to deconstruct
Nanook Revisited.
You have this, what
we were talking
about as the voice of God
narration in the first class.
Very tried and true documentary
technique that leads
to a certain kind of
relationship or feeling
with the subject.
This guy with a
plummy British accent
translating what the Inuit women
are saying, and pronouncing
the situation that you're
going to be finding yourself
in the film.
So it's interesting because
the point of the film--
and it does it quite
effectively in many places--
is to kind of deconstruct Nanook
of the North and deconstruct
Flaherty's technique.
But at the same time, it's also
constructing its own reality
and its own point of
view with this narration
and with the people flying
in at the beginning,
swooping into the village.
I mean, it's a very
interesting thing
where they're deconstructing
this other film
for very legitimate reasons.
But that other film is
also extremely personal
and extremely oriented
towards people in a way
that that one isn't quite.
So quite a dissonance there.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: The point
I was thinking was that,
so on the one hand, you have
people responding to Nanook,
again, as if it's a family
album and it's really important
to have these images.
On the other hand, you also
hear critical commentary
like one of the TV
producers talking
about the gramophone scene, I
mean, clearly not being happy
about the portrayal there.
And so people were
being somewhat critical
of the representations, but
at the same time thinking
that it's really, again,
a really important
historical record
for people to have,
so this kind of complicated
relationship to the film.
And then we have Starting
Fire with Gunpowder, which
I believe came out in '97.
'91, I'm sorry.
That came out in '91.
Thoughts about that?
AUDIENCE: I thought
comparing the last two
films we watched, the sense
of agency in the third film
was so much stronger just
because of the different
narrator, somebody
of the community.
And in the third film, they
had a different relationship
with technology than
in Nanook Revisited,
in which they were still kind
of passively watching this movie
and criticizing, but still
watching, and laughing,
and looking at the pictures.
And then the third one,
they had a lot more control
of the technology.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Right.
So it's Intuit media producers
using this technology
for their own ends
and constructing
the media for the questions
that they're interested in.
AUDIENCE: I think it's
really interesting how--
I mean, maybe just the fragment
we watched, but she really
does stress that it
isn't an Inuit film,
and it's made in this
language, and there
is more filming in that the
language, in the written
language, brings the
community together,
and these things come
up over and over again.
If it was a documentary
about TV in Italy,
people wouldn't be stressing
that it brings Italians
together and it's filmed
in Italian because it would
be like, of course, that's
what TV does, communicates
messages and is usually
in the local language.
So it signifies that
this intense relationship
with the technological
or political significance
and maybe the hopes
attached to this project.
CHRIS BOEBEL: An
interesting analogy to that.
In parts of Europe,
though, is the stress
on having a national
film industry,
in many countries, a
native, quote, unquote,
"language film
industry," that are
supported by the government.
I mean you think about Eastern
European countries, Germany,
I mean lots of
countries in Europe
have a film industry because
the government intervenes
to make sure that they
have a film industry.
And it's for reasons of
language, and culture,
and defining yourself
in opposition
to these hegemonic film
industries like the America
film industry and
increasingly even Bollywood.
So I mean, I think
film often ends up
carrying those kinds of weights
for communities, cultures.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: But I think
what Catarina is getting at,
I mean, this move towards
Inuit media making
is also part of a particular
kind of social movement
which gets talked
about, if you're
interested in the recommended
reading for this class,
there's an article by
Faye Ginsberg called
Screen Memories, where she talks
about the work of filmmakers
Zach Kunuk.
And he's the person who did the
fiction film that I mentioned,
Fast Runner, and
he's also the one
who did the documentary about
climate change that just got
made this year that
we're going to see
a little later in the class.
And what Faye
Ginsberg argues there
is that for many Indigenous
groups in different parts
of the world, that
often the discussion
around media technologies is
that this is modern technology
doing things to them.
And she talks about how,
for many Indigenous groups,
they talk about both the
power that outside media
representations can have to do
things like encourage language
loss within particular
communities, which
is a real issue here.
But she also argues
that how many
groups have mobilized around
using media for their own ends,
for purposes of
cultural revitalization.
And so it's very
interesting if you
see a film like Fast Runner,
that film by Zach Kunuk,
it's a fiction film that's
based on a 16th century myth.
And it's kind of like
Flaherty's in the sense
that it's meant to be part
of this pre-European contact
portrait of Inuit society.
But it's done for very
different reasons.
So it's very interesting
to see them back-to-back,
because they're both kind
of historical nostalgia
pieces in a way, but
for different ends.
Whereas Flaherty's
historical nostalgia
is more a European
romantic primitivist idea,
and on the Inuit end it's
kind of a romantic historical
nostalgia piece,
but for the purposes
of cultural revitalization
among Inuit peoples themselves,
and to pull people together
both socially and politically.
So they're interesting
to see back-to-back.
So I would encourage
anybody who's
interested in these
issues and have
time-- which I know all of
you have so much extra time.
CHRIS BOEBEL: In
terms of portrayal,
one interesting thing
about the Fast Runner
is that, like Nanook,
you have people dressed
in traditional Inuit garb,
hunting in traditional ways,
and as Chris said, it's
set in the 16th century.
But at the end
during the credits,
you see all of the actors
dressing contemporary garb,
riding snowmobiles--
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Black leather jackets.
CHRIS BOEBEL: --and
black leather jackets.
And the whole point
of that is to make
clear to anybody who might be
remotely confused, that this
was a fiction film, these were
actors, there were costumes,
there were sets, and
it's not real life.
It's not this eternal
culture, Inuit culture.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
So just to conclude
our discussion of
Flaherty, because we
need to move on to Vertov.
So Flaherty, again, has been
this incredibly influential
figure within documentary film.
But there's also been a
lot of more recent debate
about his work, partly based
on some of the things that we
talked about, what
kinds of representations
were being constructed, what
about the stuff that was
faked in the film, and how
do people think about that?
And I think some of
those historical debates
have kind of--
some of those debates
have died down a bit now.
Basically, you
had the two sides.
One side that was celebrating
the work of Flaherty
and the other side was
the more revisionist side
that said, look, there are
also quite problematic aspects
of these representations.
And I think now at
this point, the idea
is more that it's a
bit of both, that it
was a very innovative and
important piece of work
for a variety of reasons.
And it also has remained
important to Inuit people
themselves again because
of its historical record.
At the same time,
it was very much
coming out of a particular
historical context that
very much did feed into European
romantic primitivist ideas
at the time.
So it's a complicated piece
that has some of both going on.
Any final thoughts that
any of you had before we
move on to our
discussion of our Vertov.
So now we're going
back to the 1920s.
So this film, Man With a
Movie Camera came out in 1929.
So it's slightly later than the
Flaherty Nanook of the North.
It's an extremely different film
in almost every kind of way.
It was made by a
Russian filmmaker,
Dziga Vertov, who was born
in 1896, died in 1954.
His name was a pseudonym.
It meant spinning top.
His actual name was Dennis
Kaufman, original name.
He is born as a son of
Jewish intellectuals
in an outlying region of Russia.
And as you know
from the reading,
Vertov started out
editing newsreels
for the new Soviet
government right
after it was formed, when
he was in his early 20s.
And he made many films
later on with his wife,
Elizaveta Svilova--
sorry, I can't
pronounce it correctly--
and his brother,
Mikhail Kaufman.
And often in his
writings referred to them
as the Council of
three, and they
issued a number of
manifestos about film
and about a new kind
of film journalism
that they were arguing was
about capturing the, quote,
unquote, "prose of life."
He was an impassioned believer
in the ability of film
to allow people to
look at their world
in new ways, which you've
seen as manifestos.
And it was also,
he saw it as part
of this kind of thinking
about the world in new ways
is also for him being
associated with the political
transformations
that he associated
with the Russian
revolution at the time.
Later on, he became involved
in more feature length films.
And he also developed an
increasingly complicated
relationship to the
Soviet government,
particularly under
Stalin as things
became more bureaucratized.
Vertov was a very independent
minded artist and filmmaker,
and he was increasingly
seen as being anti planning
and marginalized within
Soviet filmmaking.
But despite his
marginalization over time
within Soviet filmmaking,
he's had an enormous influence
on European filmmakers,
particularly avant garde
filmmakers, who still consider
this to be a classic film.
And it's this film
in particular,
Man With a Movie Camera, that's
most widely known of his work.
So this film is a
dawn to dusk portrait
of an archetypal Soviet city.
And it was actually shot in
three different cities, Moscow,
Kyiv, and Odessa.
A couple of questions that you
should be thinking about as you
watch this film.
What is the particular vision
of filmmaking that Vertov is
trying to get at in this film?
And so he put out
a newsletter called
Kino Pravda or Film Truth.
So this question of,
what was film truth
to Vertov What did
he mean by this term?
What was he trying to capture
through his documentary
filmmaking work?
And also, he had a
very strong vision
of science and technology.
How does that come
out in the film?
What's the portrayals of science
and technology in this piece?
And then the third
question being,
how does this film
compare with Nanook?
Because again, it's an
extremely different style
than Robert Flaherty's piece.
If we think of the
two of them together,
both coming out of the
context of the '20s, what
do those contrasting styles
potentially suggest for us?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
OK, so you see at work
doing a variety of things.
You see different
life events or you
see babies being born
in a hospital, people
getting married, people in
divorce court, a funeral.
Towards the end of the day
when the sun starts going down,
you see recreation people
going out to sports events
or to other kinds
of entertainment.
And then the last piece
we want to show you--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
Again, you haven't gotten
to see all of this film.
But what is it about?
AUDIENCE: It's about different--
so what I got out of
it is that it's, like,
trying to say that technology
is like stagnant without people,
and people are stagnant
without technology.
But film has, it's like, on its
own that people can embrace.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah,
so it's making an argument
about film and technology, a
bunch of different arguments.
Other expansions on
that, or thoughts?
AUDIENCE: Questioning
[INAUDIBLE] manipulation.
But it's not like he's
trying to hide it.
He's trying to show you
what the camera can do.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Trying to
show what the camera can do.
Is there a narrative
to this film?
AUDIENCE: A day in the life?
I mean, not quite,
but it does show
from the beginning
where there's nobody out
and then lots of people are out.
And then people sitting down
watching a movie at the end.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
So you don't-- and again,
because you only saw a piece
of it, it might be
a little less clear.
But again, it is supposed
to be this dawn to dusk
in an archetypal city.
And again, it's images from
three different cities that
are edited together
to make it appear
as if it's like this
quintessential Soviet city.
So you see people waking
up at the beginning
and then they go to work.
And there's a lot of stuff in
the middle about people working
and watching technology
and machines move as part
of everyday kinds of work.
And then, as I
mentioned, there's
all these different
kinds of life events
that you're shown going on.
And then towards the end of the
day, people are done working.
You see various
recreation scenes, people
going to sporting events.
And then at the end,
they go to the cinema.
And they watch this film.
So there's one loose
plot line that's
about the dawn to dusk in the
life of an archetypal city.
And then intertwined
with that, you
have this thread
about the filmmaker.
So what's the thread
about the filmmaker?
AUDIENCE: It was interesting
that it starts with this camera
man on a camera.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: The scene, I mean, the
film starts with the camera--
two cameras.
One camera man with the
camera and the camera.
And it carries on
throughout the movie,
the idea of the eye watching
the eye or the camera watching
the camera, and then people
watching the camera that
shoot the camera.
It's kind of a
chain of the camera
or the eyes looking
at each other.
And the aperture of the eye
and the curtain opening,
it was just like, [INAUDIBLE].
And motion pictures
versus static pictures
in the beginning.
It was also interesting
because the music,
the minimalist music,
the progression of starts
slow and then the editing was
very with the-- and with music.
I think it was new in this
one rather like the other ones
that we watched before that.
CHRIS BOEBEL: So the
music just interrupt,
but the music, this would
have been shown with music.
But the music would have
varied and it wouldn't
have been exactly this music.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: But
I believe Vertov did--
I mean, he started out early
on doing avant garde sound
compositions.
And I believe that
this was actually
a reconstruction movie.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah, and it's
inspired by it or something,
yeah.
But I mean--
AUDIENCE: The music
wasn't original?
CHRIS BOEBEL: The music, I
mean this is a silent film,
but they would be played--
when these films were
shown, this one or Nanook,
there would have been an
orchestra or some kind
of musical accompaniment.
And I think that this
soundtrack is inspired
by or a reconstruction
of the kinds of things
that Vertov experimented
with musically.
So it is a separate thing.
AUDIENCE: It wasn't
based on the music.
CHRIS BOEBEL: It's a little bit
of a not quite 1 to 1 ratio.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
So the music was
done by the composer Michael
Nyman, who did research
on the period, the incredible
artistic creativity that
immediately followed
the Russian Revolution.
And so it's based on
research imagining
what music might have been.
AUDIENCE: But I think
they were very closely
related, weren't they?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah.
Well, the editing
is kind of stunning.
I mean, if you think
about the time period
and then compare
that to Nanook, it's
just a completely different
relationship to film,
a completely different
relationship to editing,
and as people have said,
what the camera can do.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
But before we get
into comparison of
Nanook and Vertov,
because I think that's where
we want this to go, but first
can we get out a bit
more a bit about Vertov
and what's going on here?
So we have the
parallels as you note
between the human
eye and the camera
eye going back and forth,
making comparisons between them.
And what kind of
argument is he making?
Do you guys have a--
AUDIENCE: There's a bit of a
danger in like, I mean, he's
climbing, like, a bridge
over where the train's coming
in and then also going
underneath the train
track and stuff.
And as soon as like
the train looks
like it might have
run him over, like,
the girl wakes up, like
something has gone on.
I don't know if she's, like,
related to him or something,
supposedly, but yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's so beautiful.
And I mean, it's incredible
how the camera has
a life on its own, the
cameraman is trying to--
you have the cameraman
trying to film
what the camera wants to film.
And it's never really there.
It's always the climbing,
and making the effort,
and the camera is
showing all these things
that you would never be able
to see unmediated by the camera
and unmediated by
the process of making
the film that shows the kind
of montage and screening.
It's really dazzling.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Mm-hmm.
So a lot of different
threads going on.
Maybe one place to start
in terms of Vertov,
one thing that you might have
gotten from your readings
was that he was
heavily influenced
by the futurist
movement in Europe.
So the futurist
movement coming out
of being inspired partly
by Italian futurism,
French cubism, any sense of what
those artistic movements were
about?
AUDIENCE: So there are
a bunch of young male--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: In Italy in the '20s,
and they travel a lot in Paris
to see what the
Cubists are up to.
But the Cubists are
mainly interested in space
and in how emptiness is
full and bring it up.
But the futurists are
interested in movement.
And this is why the Cubists only
painted like brown and white
and the futurists
paint with colors,
because colors is
associated with movement
and movement is
associated with what
is cool things the
young males like,
like sports, fast cars,
war, Italy at the time
is trying to have a couple
of colonies in Africa.
And these guys are
really excited about it.
They're excited
about first place,
they're excited
about breaking down
the land which we have this
future manifesto where they
develop a way of writing
without giving up punctuation,
like rules of punctuation
and rules of plot.
And there is a lot of
communication between Paris,
Italy, and Russia.
A lot of back and forth.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah, exactly.
So part of the influence on
Vertov of the futurist movement
would be being a fascination
with the future, which
was very much associated with
the possibilities of technology
as they were seen by
at least some people
during this time period.
So a fascination with machinery,
modern technologies of various
kinds, a fascination
with movement,
a fascination linked to both of
those about what can the camera
eye do differently or allow
us to see about the world that
the human eye can't?
So this is where a lot of
Vertov was coming from.
And like some of the
other futurists where
he wrote a lot of manifestos--
for those of you
who are interested,
it's on the website.
But just to read you a bit of
one of those where he writes,
"I am kino eye,"
meaning cinema eye.
"I am a mechanical eye.
I am machine show you the
world as only I can see it.
Now and forever, I free
myself from human immobility.
I am in constant motion.
I draw near then
away from objects.
I crawl under, I
climb onto them.
I move space with
the muzzle of--
I'm sorry-- I move
apace with the muzzle
of a galloping horse.
I plunge full
speed into a crowd.
I outstrip running soldiers.
I fall on my back.
I ascend with an airplane.
I plunge and soar together with
plunging and soaring bodies."
And he goes on and on
celebrating the movement,
the technology, the camera
eye, that the camera is
superior to the human eye.
CHRIS BOEBEL:
Directly contradicts
what I said in the
first class, but it's
coming from a very
different perspective.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Debatable point.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Yeah.
Yeah.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: But
similar to some of what
was discussed in last week's
class, a fascination, well,
what can you see differently
with the camera lens
than you would, potentially,
with the human eye?
And the human eye--
and a lot of people
have critiqued Vertov
for this, that there's
this incredible celebration
of machinery and technology,
but the human eye is amazing.
That actually, the camera
lens can't do a lot of things
that the human eye
is capable of doing.
But there are some things
that the camera can
do that the human eye can't do.
And so last week we saw some
of the microcinematography,
the time lapse, the
fascinating perspective
you get by doing
time lapse filmmaking
to see things in a new way.
And so here, Vertov's
fascination with, how can we
see using the camera lens?
And so as part of
that, you get this kind
of heroic portrait
of the filmmaker
as this hero that's going to
get out there and get people
to think differently
using the camera
eye from all these
different kinds of angles.
That you can capture
things in time,
see it at another
time period, you
could get perspectives on
things that you wouldn't
be able to see before,
you can have the filmmaker
climb under the train in a pit
and capture that angle, which
the rest of us could
do if we did that.
But the camera eye
allowing those kinds of
perspectives to be
recorded and to be shared.
And in addition to this,
the focus on editing.
So what is the
editing like here?
And how is it
different than what we
saw in Flaherty, for example?
Matt?
AUDIENCE: I mean, he tried
to make the editing really
profound at the same
time really obvious
that he put a lot of effort into
making it profound by the fact
that her he had
to expose himself.
So you know the guy who's
actually doing the editing.
And also, it shows
woman doing the editing.
And then he does some
really ridiculous thing
where they're doing the two
scene split in the upside down.
So it's almost like
controlled chaos in a way.
It was like he took
everything and then
just put it all together
into something logical.
CHRIS BOEBEL: Right.
Whereas, I mean,
again, with Nanook,
you're using editing to create
an illusion of the way we
perceive reality with
our eyes and our brains,
taking in a scene, close ups,
establishing shots, pans.
Here it's very much saying,
no, editing is its own thing.
Editing for the sake of
editing is what filmmaking is.
And this links up to
theories of montage
which is, like,
sequences of shot, which
were very big in Soviet cinema.
But it's basically
saying, again, this
is not the human eye, this is
not the human brain perceiving
stuff.
We're doing something,
in his opinion,
better, something you can't do
with your eye and your brain.
And here's how it works.
I'm going to break
it down for you.
I'm going to show you
the person doing it.
Then I'm going to show
you how film works,
stills going into motion.
I'm going to show you what
happens when you take this shot
and put it next to that
shot and how it changes
when this shot is not
next to that shot,
and how you reverse them,
and how you split screen,
and what that does.
I mean, it's really interesting.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
So just to follow up
what Chris was saying.
So montage, being strongly--
a particular kind
of montage, anyway,
being strongly associated
with early Soviet filmmaking.
So how is meaning created then?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: The juxtaposition
of images [INAUDIBLE]
associations [INAUDIBLE].
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
And what kind of
images do you want--
or what,
philosophically, are you
trying to do when you're
juxtaposing these images?
AUDIENCE: You're saying
they're connected
and also depending
on how you edit it,
it might be, like,
making it more glamorous
or something, or
different things.
In this case, it
was [INAUDIBLE]..
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
So again, unlike Flaherty,
where the editing
would be to create a
sense of continuity
and a sense of realism
and being in a space,
here, the meaning, what is
the meaning created out of?
It's taking things that are
completely different, putting
them in relation to each other.
And the idea being that if
you have something different
over here, something
over here, and you
put it and you jam it up
against the other thing,
that it creates a new
kind of meaning by putting
those things together.
So the Soviet idea of
montage and meaning
then coming out of
the fact that you're
taking disparate elements and
by using the camera in this way,
you're creating new ways of
seeing the world because you're
juxtaposing images that
you wouldn't normally
be juxtaposing in experience.
But by juxtaposing them
in certain kinds of ways,
you can make arguments,
you can express ideas,
you create meaning.
That's how you create meaning
is through the montage
rather than creating meaning
through a sense of continuity,
or a sense that you
actually were in a place,
or that you're capturing
some kind of reality.
OK so Kino Pravda or
film truth for Vertov
means something very different
than the sense of truth in film
might mean for Flaherty
or for other people.
Here, it's very
much not the truth
of trying to be realistic
to people's experiences
of day-to-day life, but a sense
of being a certain kind of film
truth where you're
trying to use the camera
and what the camera can
do to get people to think
about the world in a new
way, and according to him,
kind of have some kind of truth
revelation about the world
and how the world works
through these arguments that
construct it through
the montage in the film.
So it's a very particular
conception of film truth.
And that's quite
different than the one
that you would often hear
people talking about,
say, in the United States
in relation to documentary.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And one
way to think about it
is in terms of manipulation.
I mean, all film on one level
or another is a manipulation.
And with the Flaherty
approach, the whole point
is to hide the manipulation.
All of the stuff we were
talking about in terms
of the background, behind
the scenes, all of the things
that were done, all of the
changes that were made,
the repositioning of the
camera, the way it's edited,
it's all designed to make you
forget about that as a viewer
and just immerse
yourself in this world
that he's constructed, even
though it's a documentary.
Whereas here, the
manipulation is the point.
It's all n your face.
The whole point of it is to jam
it down your throat as a viewer
and say, revel in it.
This is exciting.
This is what this art form
is about, this manipulation.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
And how does this
relate to narrative, a sense
of narrative being a question?
I mean again, the question,
what's the narrative here?
I mean, we talked about
loosely there's certain themes.
Whether we want to see it
as a fully fledged narrative
might be something else.
But one of the things that
Vertov and the Council of three
very strongly argued for is
that they want to break--
that this is about film
experiments and the idea
is to completely break
with theater and literature
and other kinds of
fiction filmmaking.
So they're arguing
for a radical break,
that they want to break with
narratives that you commonly
found in Hollywood films
that were being made,
starting to be made during
this period with literature,
with theater, and
they're saying,
no, we want to completely
get rid of that
and do something different.
And just to read a little
bit more of the manifesto,
Vertov writes, "We proclaim
the old films based
on the romance, theatrical
films, and the like
to be leprous.
Keep them away, exclamation
mark, keep your eyes off them.
They're mortally dangerous,
contagious, exclamation mark."
I mean, it's really fun to
read some of the manifestos.
They're quite manifesto-like.
"We affirm the future of cinema
art by denying its present.
Cinematography must die so that
the art of cinema may live.
We call for its death
to be hastened."
So basically making a
very radical critique
of other kinds of filmmaking
that would be out there,
he would be making a very
radical critique of, say,
Flaherty's style
of making film that
has more continuities
with fiction filmmaking
at the time and other
kinds of storytelling.
What about the
relationship to people?
So again, think about
Flaherty and Nanook
of the North and this piece.
What's the
relationship to people
that gets conveyed
by the filmmaker
in both of these pieces?
How is it different?
AUDIENCE: In Nanook where
like one family that you're
kind of identifying
more specifically Nanook
versus in this one, there's
no one person that you really
follow too much.
I mean, there's a little bit
but they cut back and forth
to the same person,
but it's just
like the whole population,
which is kind of, I guess,
the Soviet culture
they're trying to--
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
Is it about people?
AUDIENCE: There's no distinction
between people and, like,
inanimate objects it seems.
Like, they just--
I don't know.
Sometimes, like, in some of
the parts, there was, like,
the girl doing
something that related,
there was a parallel to
something, like, physical.
And in the Nanook
story, it was all
based on the relationship with
people, what they're doing,
their interaction with
the world around them.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: Yeah.
So in Nanook, so it's
about individuals
following individual
stories, creating a narrative
in that way.
And here, to the extent--
I mean, certainly there
are people in there.
But it's more of a visual
representation of society,
in a sense, if you want
to see it that way.
So the idea is not to capture
individuals and follow them
in their experiences,
but to convey
some kind of more abstract idea
of what, say, Soviet society
would be and to see
its pieces as working,
as being about movement, maybe
about the interdependencies
and the division
of labor where you
see different categories
of people doing
different kinds of things.
There's also a critique
implicit in here.
For those of you who read--
you might have read some of
the background information
but others you wouldn't.
So immediately after
the Russian Revolution,
there was a lot of creative
dynamic stuff happening, also
very difficult
times economically.
And so Lenin, at
a certain point,
instituted the new
economic program
which was a bit of a
retreat from the revolution
at that point.
And so it was more allowing
more capitalist relations
to re-emerge a bit.
And partly, Vertov
is making a critique.
I mean, you see some
people lying on benches
and then you see other people
who look quite prosperous.
So I think part of
what's going on there
is making a critique,
Vertov making
a critique with the new economic
policies during this period
that you have a resurgence
of economic inequalities
that would have been there
before the revolution.
So he's also making
his own argument
within the context of that
post-revolutionary period
in Russia.
So for those of you who haven't
done the background reading,
that's something that would
have come out in there.
But that's partly
what's also going on
with those juxtapositions.
But in general, then, the
sense that you get of people
is a sense of
society in a broader
sense, the relationships and
connections between people
as part of Soviet society,
it's a collective image rather
than being about individual
stories and narration.
And again, reading
from the manifesto,
Vertov writes, "We
temporarily exclude man
as a subject for film.
Our path leads
through the poetry
of machines, from
the bungling citizen
to the perfect electric man,
in revealing the machine soul,
in causing the worker
to love his workbench,
the peasant his tractor,
the engineer his engine,
we introduce creative joy
into all mechanical labor.
We bring people into closer
kinship with machines.
We foster new people."
So what's the kind of
image of society here?
AUDIENCE: Each person
has a role in a bigger
society which he's trying to
show how it all works together.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
And the relationship
to technology here?
AUDIENCE: Very much at MIT.
We love the technology.
That's what going
to save the world.
We don't need politics, we
just need better iPhones.
I mean, it's beautiful.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: So it's very
much about people's kinship
with machines.
And again, a very
different image
of modern technology
than you find in Flaherty
just a few years apart.
So you're seeing two
different trends,
two different artistic
traditions happening
not that far apart
chronologically,
but this one being very
much about the celebration
of modern technology
and where it can lead,
and wanting to bring people into
closer kinship with machines,
and what can we see
through these technologies,
how does it let us
see the world anew.
And in Flaherty, using the
newer technology, but also
a critique of what he
would have been seeing
is as modern social
life, looking
at other kinds of technologies
with longer histories,
again, in this kind of
romantic primitivist mode,
but also a certain
amount of real respect
for those other kinds
of technologies.
So again, you've got these two
filmmakers, both incredibly
influential
filmmakers, doing very
interesting, fascinating,
innovative things,
but coming from completely
different perspectives
on these topics.
AUDIENCE: Well,
you have to think,
the reason it is in parallel
because they both have
romantic representation, so
it's very much a representation
of machines here.
They're beautiful,
the mood is perfect.
We don't really see
what these machines
do when they break down.
It's just about
as if they were--
you can see this kind
of timeless world
in the same way the people
are represented in Flaherty.
So I think it's nice.
CHRIS BOEBEL: And one
other thing about Vertov,
at the beginning, he
very much describes
the film as an experiment.
I mean, the film
itself, film technology
is one of the technologies
that he's talking about
and that he's completely
obsessed with.
And it's a scientific
or pseudoscientific
representation.
He doesn't call himself
a film director,
he calls himself a chief
experimentalist or something
like that.
And the film itself
is an experiment.
And that raises a very,
very interesting question
that we're going to return to
periodically as we make films
and look at films,
which is, what's
the relationship
between documentaries,
and documentary filmmaking,
and science itself?
We're talking about
making science films.
But when you make a
documentary, you go out,
you collect evidence,
you collect data,
you process the data
in various ways,
and you come to some
kind of conclusion.
And there are parallels.
I mean, certainly it's a very
different process in many ways,
but there are parallels
between that and science.
And Vertov is saying, parallels?
Hell, it's the same thing.
But as we go on, we're
going to be looking
at, what's the relationship
between those two processes
and truth, reality, whatever
word you want to use
to describe what we're after.
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
So just to conclude,
just to throw out
a couple of things
to be thinking about then,
following what Chris is saying.
As we go through the
rest of the class
and as you think about making
final projects for yourself
and different kind of
pieces, to thinking
about the different
techniques you
might be interested in using.
I mean, what kind of
story do you want to tell?
Do you want to tell a story
from the point of view
of an individual and
follow him or her around?
Do you want to use montage
to tell your story?
Is the focus going
to be on editing
as a way to construct the ideas
in the piece that you're doing?
Do you want it to be more
narrative-driven or more
non-narrative driven?
Do you want it to be a realist
aesthetic where you're drawing
attention away from the camera?
Or this is highly reflexive.
In some ways, the
Vertov piece is
very contemporary in
the sense of being
reflexive in the
sense of focusing
on the process of
filmmaking itself as being
part of what it's doing.
Would you want to be
reflexive in your filmmaking?
Would you include references
to yourself as the filmmaker?
Shots of yourself talking
to people or your hand
going out and doing
various things?
Or I mean, do you want
to include yourself
as part of this process?
Do you, in relation to issues
of science and technology,
do you want to
celebrate technology
or are you interested
in exploring
other kinds of issues?
What kinds of
relationships do you
want to foster with the
subjects that you're going
to be portraying in your film?
Do you want to have a
collaborative relationship
that Flaherty had,
to some degree,
even though it was
a hierarchical one,
it was still based on a certain
degree of collaboration.
Is that your
interest in creating
that kind of relationship
with your subjects?
Or are you interested
more in not so
much the subject's
point of view, but more
what you want to
say as a filmmaker,
using those images that you take
to say to say something else?
What kinds of
relationships do you
want to foster in the
process of making films?
Anything else I'm leaving out?
CHRIS BOEBEL: Well--
CHRISTINE WALLEY:
I'm sure a lot.
CHRIS BOEBEL: A whole
semester's worth.
Yeah, we'll keep going.
CHRISTINE WALLEY: But
anyway, so the idea
is to be thinking about these
completely-- two classic films
that have been incredibly
influential and powerful,
completely different
technique, styles,
ways of editing,
everything else,
and to think about the range
of choices that you all have.
And when you go to think about
doing your own pieces, what
interests you, what do
you want to drive you,
what do you want to drive the
piece that you're going to do?
CHRIS BOEBEL: So,
just the last word,
just looking ahead to Friday.
These are both silent films.
On Friday, we're going
to introduce sound.
You got to play with
the camera last week,
so now we're going to
take the next step.
And we'll also look at some
of the things that people shot
and talk about what
worked and what didn't.